soll pluto jetzt wieder ein planet
werden 2006 hatte er ja seinen planeten
status verloren die internationale
astronomische union hatte ihre kriterien
bezüglich des planeten status geändert
jetzt wird die ganze diskussion und
pluto wieder neu entfacht denn ein
astronomie team hat fakten
zusammengetragen die entscheidung von
2006 in frage stellen also jetzt doch
alles ganz anders klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen das war
wirklich eine mehr als denkwürdige
änderung unseres sonnensystems doch die
neuen kriterien der internationalen
astronomischen union iau aus dem jahr
2006 ließen keinen zweifel
pluto war raus aus der planeten riege
denn seit zwölf jahren regelt die eu in
einer neuen definition welche kriterien
himmelskörper erfüllen müssen um als
planet zu gelten
die drei kriterien sind die folgenden
erstens die himmelskörper müssen ein
gestirn umkreisen zweitens sie müssen
durch ihre eigene schwerkraft abgerundet
sein dritter
die orbit sollte freigeräumt von anderen
objekten seien schon damals gab es
heftige kritik an der entscheidung vor
allem an dem teil der fordert dass ein
planet seine umlaufbahn völlig gesäubert
haben müsste
denn dies sei selbst bei der erde dem
mars oder dem jupiter nicht der fall
in deren umlaufbahn nämlich mehrere
zehntausende asteroiden kreisen ein
forschungsteam aus florida hat jetzt in
einem artikel mehrere argumente
zusammengetragen die die definition der
iaa und komplett in frage stellen dann
so findet einer der beteiligten forscher
einen stern harte worte
ich denke die eu hat sich damit wirklich
blamiert sie haben ein problem für sich
selbst und für die astronomie produziert
das team aus den usa hat für ihre
argumentation wissenschaftliche arbeiten
aus den letzten 200 jahren analysiert
und nach dem begriff planet durchforstet
das ergebnis lediglich eine arbeit habe
das zentrale kriterium der eu-definition
korrekt genutzt dagegen hat das ziel
mehr als 100 beispiele gefunden in denen
der begriff planet von den jeweiligen
autorinnen und autoren so eingesetzt
wurde dass er gegen die geltenden
definition verstößt vor allem das dritte
kriterium stößt den verfassern und
verfasserin
artikels auf die definition der eu führe
dazu dass gleiche himmelskörper anders
definiert werden bzw eingestuft werden
und das einzig und allein aufgrund der
anzahl ihrer begleiter in den
umlaufbahnen ein großes problem dass
forscher stellen an dem beispiel der
erde erläutert denn selbst unser
heimmarkt daneben wäre demnach in der
pluto umlaufbahn kein planet mehr denn
in einer bestimmten zone im sonnensystem
macht es die hohe anzahl an brocken und
möglich die großen umlaufbahn ganz frei
zu halten so das argument des us
forschungsteams konkret befindet sich
diese region des sonnensystems etwa auf
der höhe von uranus und neptun dazu
stern in einem interview mit space.com
auch die erde würde das nicht schaffen
das gebiet wäre einfach zu groß
das bedeutet aber auch im umkehrschluss
und das müsst ihr euch ja vorstellen
selbst wenn alle neuen planeten unseres
sonnensystems zwillinge der erde wären
würden sie nach der definition der eu
eben nicht alle als planeten gelten dazu
der autor man hätte neuen identische
objekte von denen man sechs einen
planeten nennen würde und drei nicht das
ist ungefähr so als wenn man sagen würde
ich nenne eine kuh nur dann eine kuh
wenn sie nicht in einer herde ist doch
das ist nicht das einzige argument des
forschungsteams gegen wie neue
definition des planeten status es
argumentiert dass der orbit vom planeten
und eben auch die menge seiner begleiter
dynamisch ist deswegen sein dieses
kriterium völlig ungeeignet ihn für die
definition eines planeten status
heranzuziehen dazu heißt es in der
studie
sie sind daher keine grundlegende
eigenschaft eines himmelskörpers sondern
beschreiben nur sein momentanes umfeld
auch der begriff des freiräumen im
dritten kriterium sei sehr ungenau
was sie damit genau meint bleibe offen
so die studie
zitat sie haben nicht festgelegt was sie
genau mit freiräumen des ortes meinen
damit das kriterium wörtlich nimmt gebe
es gar keine planeten denn keiner ist
allein auf seinem orbit und tatsächlich
viele planeten wie etwa die erde oder
auch der jupiter haben begleiter in
ihrer umlaufbahn trojaner genannt
das dritte kriterium der planeten
definition ist laut des forschungsteams
also durchweg kritisch zu sehen
die studie fordert jetzt auf dieses
kriterium zu verzichten stattdessen sei
die beurteilung anderer merkmale wichtig
die die tatsächlichen
wichtigen merkmale eines himmelskörpers
beschreibt wie zum beispiel das zweite
kriterium der eu-definition die
abrundung der himmelskörper durch ihre
eigene schwerkraft ein meilenstein in
der entwicklung eines kleineren
himmelskörpers so das forschungsteam und
somit durchaus charakteristisch für den
planeten status denn dadurch werde eine
aktive geologie des objektes losgetreten
und genau dies sei bei pluto der fall
eine atmosphäre mit wolken dünen und
eisvulkanen beherbergt der
herabgestuften experiment zu geben auch
fließende gletscher um vielleicht sogar
einen flüssigen ozean unter seiner
eiskruste enthüllt hatten dass daten der
nasa raumsonde new horizons dazu das
team aus florida pluto ist damit
dynamischer und lebendiger als der mars
der einzige planet der eine noch
komplexere geologie besitzt ist die erde
das fazit der wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler all diese fakten könnte
man nicht so stehen lassen stattdessen
sei es höchste zeit die eu planeten
definition wieder zu ändern
die entscheidung von 2006 sei durch
personen getroffen worden die nicht
wirklich ahnung vom fach hätten so das
team der studie und weiter wir schlagen
vor den konsens über eine planetarische
taxonomie nicht über den
wissenschaftlichen prozess einer
abstimmung zu erreichen sondern durch
auswertung der wissenschaftlichen
literatur und diskussion eine reaktion
der beiden wissenschaftler die die
entscheidung von 2006 maßgeblich
mitbestimmten
die gibt es auch schon mike brown vom
california institute of technology der
sich bei twitter auch pluto killer nennt
zeigt sich überhaupt nicht beeindruckt
ebenso sein kollege konstantin bettingen
er fordert ein ende des streits wichtig
sei doch weiter zu den eigenschaften der
himmelskörper zu forschen
zitat unwichtig dagegen wie wir sie
nennen so schreibt der auf twitter
hört sich wie ein rückzugsgefecht an und
vor allem ist dass wir wissenschaft
etwas untypisch so unwissenschaftlich
vorzugehen liegt ein wenig den verdacht
nahe als wären die übeltäter damals wohl
wissend so schlampig gewesen ja und wenn
ihr zu diesem und zu allen anderen
themen kein video mehr verpassen wollt
dann habe ich am ende des videos einen
kleinen trick für euch jetzt aber eine
kleine sensation
keine werbung mehr auf pixel mehr schon
angefangen immer mehr videos sind
werbefrei
dank eurer hilfe immer wenn wir
entsprechend viele kanal mitglieder
gewonnen haben schalten wir die werbung
vor einem video ab werdet also mitglied
hier unter dem video draufklicken und
ihr bekommt noch exklusive extras wie
des livestreams und noch ein paar
weitere privilegien für einen kleinen
beitrag und der trick der geht so wenn
er immer garantiert über aktuelle videos
informiert werden wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp nur da bekommt ihr das
aktuelle video deutlich vor allen
anderen von mir persönlich auf euer
handy einfach hier draufklicken und
darunter geht es weiter mit auch dafür
draufklicken ende des sonnensystems
fotografiert da geht es um die mission
der sonde new horizons bis dann bleibt
dran